ces derniers temps qu'on se le dise la
une des journaux semblent avoir quelque
peu remplacer les tribunaux
richard berry ppda est aujourd'hui
gérard depardieu à chaque semaine sa
nouvelle affaire de moeurs c'est d'abord
l'acteur richard berry qui en janvier
dernier publiquement accusé par sa fille
coline berry richman d'inceste lors
qu'elles avaient entre 6 et 10 ans pour
l'acteur richard berry visé par une
plainte ça est accusé de viol par sa
première fille coline d accusation
reprise par tous les journaux dans
l'opinion publique chacun se fait son
avis sur les réseaux sociaux ya ceux qui
soutiennent collines dont des
personnalités comme sa cousine marilou
berry et il ya les autres pour qui la
présomption d'innocence est le maître
mot
est ce que le service public que
j'apprécie temps est toujours à la
hauteur de ceux tordu ce respect de la
production de sens
c'est ensuite ppda qui le 18 février
dernier est accusé par florence porcel
d'abus sexuels lorsqu'il était à la tête
du journal de tf1 l'ancien présentateur
vedette aurait visé par une enquête pour
viol c'est le magazine closer qui
sortait de nouveaux témoignages
accablants contre le journaliste un
article dans lequel l'une des anciennes
proche de ppda déclare c'est un
prédateur sans conscience qui sera
toujours dans le déni de ce qu'il a fait
subir à de très jeunes femmes
cette semaine c'est gérard depardieu qui
s'est retrouvé au coeur de la polémique
pour des accusations de viol de la part
d'une plaignante qui aurait été agressé
au domicile de l'acteur à deux reprises
en 2018 gérard depardieu a été mise en
examen pour viols et agressions
sexuelles gérard depardieu s'est lui
aussi déclaré ne sont dans le journal
italien la repubblica
il n'y a aucune preuve je suis innocent
et je n'ai rien à craindre
quelle que soit l'issue de toutes ces
affaires le doute restera toujours dans
la tête de nombreux français alors ppda
à berry depardieu
contre le tribunal médiatique rencontre
le tribunal médiatique et dans un
instant vous savez on aura un autre
sujet tf1 doit elle annulé la diffusion
de la fiction sur michel fourniret on
aura son fils qui sera avec nous dans un
instant et ouais ça c'est vrai que c'est
un rêve voilà c'est très répandu je le
sais et ce débat aussi il est attendu
claire charles vous pensez vous que oui
bien entendu vous êtes pour le tribunal
médiatique vous êtes pour que cette
affaire sorte vous sur les réseaux
sociaux ce que délai les journaux et les
journalistes et les journaux le
reprennent alors déjà je suis contre ce
terme de tribunal médiatique parce qu'en
plus il ya en fait il ya l'idée qu'il
s'exerce à l'encontre les personnes qui
sont accusées
moi je pense que ce tribunal médiatique
en fait il est à la défaveur des
personnes qui se plaignent des victimes
parce qu'il faut bien voir que c'est un
déferlement de violence quand les
victimes parlent dans les médias c'est à
dire que depuis tout temps la société
remet sans arrêt en a en cause la parole
des victimes avec des idées que pourquoi
elle a pas parlé plus tôt
pourquoi elle n'a pas porté plainte elle
doit certainement faire ça pour l'argent
pour la notoriété etc
faut arrêter en fait de croire que le
tribunal médiatique s'il existe ça
serait uniquement en la défaveur des
personnes qui sont mises en cause
maintenant oui je pense que c'est
extrêmement important que la parole se
libère
je joue ainsi sur le fait que les
victimes elles parlent depuis toujours
mais que c'est simplement que la société
maintenant est de plus en plus prête à
écouter et donc c'est pas juste une
libération la parole c'est la société
qui évolue et effectivement c'est
vraiment cathartique pour les personnes
il faut savoir que les gens qui
témoignent sur internet que ils ont été
victimes de faits d'inceste c'est des
années de domérat familiale qu'ils ont
vécu et de défaillance de la justice qui
ne les a pas écoutés qui ne les a pas
aidés alors benjamin castadi vous êtes
contrat pont aura bien sûr la division
avocats spécialisés que je suis content
alors le premier ni là c'est
qu'évidemment il faut libérer la parole
sans la div'in fois c'est très important
on a fait beaucoup de progrès c'est une
très bonne chose le problème de libérer
la parole c'est que ppda berry deux
périodes sont des gens extrêmement connu
et que moi ce qui moi ce qui m'ennuie
alors je ne connais pas la vérité parce
qu'ils sont coupables ou non coupables
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que quoi qu'il
arrive je vous le dis dans la tête des
gens c'est fini c'est fait il son
violeur ils sont ils ont fait un délit
d'inceste et ppda a violé alors et en
plus dans ces trois cas là précisément
depardieu berry ppda ils ont tous on va
pas se mentir des réputations berry on
savait qu'il était parfois violents avec
les femmes c'est un secret pour personne
ppda on savait qu'ils étaient souvent à
600 était femmes et de parler on dit
souvent que c'est
c'est une bête donc à la base à la base
la rumeur déjà la rumeur était là et sur
la base de cette rumeur
des gens ont porté des accusations et
aujourd'hui je vous le dis depardieu
mairie et ppda sont condamnés par avance
quels que soient leur mobilité et le
problème c'est qu'effectivement si ça
continue comme ça et qu'on avance de
plus en plus avec des accusations qui
sont fausses ci qu'ils en [ __ ]
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'elle soit vraie
ou pas c'est pareil
le premier que je trouve que ça va
dénaturer la libération d'avoir ôté qu
il faut pas non plus qu'on arrive à une
situation où l'accusation vienne nuire
pour ceux qui ont envie de parler et
pour de vrai et pour des vraies raisons
alors je vous dirais c'est vrai que là
il ya tellement de ben oui y'a qui
sortent et je vous dis clair c'est vrai
que des gens disent ah on y croit monde
exactement vraiment et on dit il faut
vraiment que attention attendait après
après moi je vous dis on a honte
on n'est pas ici nicolas il faut leur
dire voilà pour l'instant comme on le
dit à chaque fois il ya deux victimes
pour l'instant et voilà il ya la victime
présumée et la victime médiatique après
le voilà l'enquète voilà la justice fera
son travail c'est ce qu'on dise avec
habib sy ton cette semaine
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué pour
les deux et c'est compliqué aussi pour
les journalistes et pour les gens
télévision de de se positionner
voilà sur sur ces affaires on passe à la
dernière partie soit gilles verdez c'est
terrible ce que dit benjamin en fait
nous aident pour le retour à la loi du
silence vague derrière vos bombes et si
tu es désolé pas du tout quand on parle
d'affaires comme ça je vous signale
qu'on s'appuie sur des plaintes le
travail des journalistes de faits divers
et des journaux même des réseaux sociaux
dès qu'il ya une plainte ça crédibilise
sa authentifie n'y a pas d'affaires qui
sort tout cas rien je ne préjuge pas je
ne préjuge pas de l'issue judiciaire
mais il ya des plaignantes quand même et
heureusement qu'il n'ya plus cette loi
du silence que vous appelez de vos voeux
depuis des années ça sort les affaires
la fois sur les réseaux dans les médias
l'omerta c'est fini aujourd'hui tout le
monde peut s'exprimer
ça a été cachée on avait amené le drame
des gens ces trois personnes seront
coupables et alors mais alors on s'est
alors
vous êtes pour que ce soit tu caches et
non non pas du tout je trouve que danser
pour le coup c'est dans ce cas précis
les mois excuse moi le la tournure c'est
que les gens sur les réseaux disent des
choses qui sont extrêmement violente à
la rencontre est pour l'instant il n'y a
rien de prouvé et rien prouvé et je ne
dis pas et je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas
les dénoncer
je dis que pour l'instant on parle d'une
tribune elle médias oui on parle du fait
que sa douleur oculaire copé est
populaire j'ai déjà pu diverses à
déconseiller médiatique et médiatique je
te citer un inconnu s'était aussi on
porte de cannes contre toi et moi et
qu'on porte plainte
il n'y aura pas façon de conséquence
itcca rigola c'est fait et c'est la
justice à deux vitesses quand on est
inconnu on a le droit d'être dénoncées
comme non alors guillaume sait pas c'est
que ce n'est pas que je suis contre le
tribunal médiatique et surtout prenez la
sphère depardieu par exemple on a
l'impression que nouvelle affaire qui
ressort mais en fait saliver d'affaires
ça a déjà été sorti en 2010 8 vous irez
anti les articles on en a déjà parlé
donc qu'est ce qui justifie
journalistique manque on reçoit l'as pas
faire aujourd'hui c'est ça la question
en fait le seul avantage de vous dire
entre guillemets si ces personnes sont
innocentes c'est qu'aujourd'hui a
tellement d'affaires chaque semaine on
détruit la carrière d'un mec il ya
tellement d'affaires qu'au final on en
parle une affaire en chasse une autre en
fait on en parle moins et on y croit
18 ans justement avocat spécialisé en
droit des médias pour ses vous aviez dit
la semaine dernière que vous étiez
contre ce tribunal populaire ce tribunal
médiatique
ce qui pose problème devant le tribunal
médiatique c'est que le combat est
inégal d'un côté vous avez une personne
qui est accusée publiquement dont le nom
est jeté en pâture et dont la réputation
est effectivement on va être détruite
parce que le doute ne profite pas à
l'accusé dans l'opinion publique et de
l'autre côté pardonnez moi c'est
important
de l'autre côté la plaignante il faut
rappeler que si elles le souhaitent
elle peut protéger son identité et c'est
la femme délit pénal que de diffus que
de diffuser l'identité de la plaignante
sans son accord dans la sphère qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui par exemple ppda la
plaignante si son nom est publié et
qu'il est publique
c'est parce qu'elle l'a bien voulu c'est
peut-être parce que aussi parce qu'elle
veut aussi essayer de concours de contes
médiatise la faire et que ça n'arrive
plus à dos la personne aussi voilà et
dans le cas de pépé 24 depardieu
la personne a souhaité garder l'anonymat
dans le cas de richard berry sa fille
coline berry croyait bien aussi alors
c'est compliqué pour réformer mais ça
doit être aussi très compliqué pour
coline berry aujourd'hui je vous dis on
line beauchamp colline berry elle était
voilà je vois moi c'est que c'est
quelqu'un que je sais déjà plein de gens
qui la connaissent et qu'ils disent
qu'aujourd'hui c'est compliqué aussi
pour elle voilà de se sortir dans la rue
parce qu'elle a été médiatisé à cause de
ça grâce à ça donc elle a pris aussi un
risque mineur voilà mais si vous
permettez c'est aussi un combat inégal
parce que dans les affaires que vous
mentionnez les personnes qui sont
accusés publiquement sont en liberté
elles ne sont pas en détention
provisoire elles peuvent s'exprimer
elles peuvent faire des droits de
réponse dans les organes de presse etc
mais imaginez par exemple dans la chair
tariq ramadan ou au départ pendant dix
mois il était en détention provisoire
comment vous vouliez que du fond ça
c'est nul ils répondent à chaque
accusation qui sortaient chaque jour
dans les médias mais m j'entendais à
l'argument le combat est inégal parce
que la personne qui est connue risque sa
réputation etc
mais si la fia n'était pas médiatiser le
combat serait inégale dans l'autre sens
c'est que la personne qui a reconnu
qu'il serait étouffé par la puissance de
l'argent qui a des grosses dalles
personne connue qui a des gros avocat
cédera n'était du coup serait
complètement étouffé qui me plaît c'est
le puissant qui est accusé de ce genre
de fait aujourd'hui
en réalité c'est le faible on le voit
bien dans ses affaires regarder la
situation de richard berry qui est
déprogrammée avant même d'avoir été jugé
il est déprogrammée sur les chaînes de
télé à juger par les scandales et j'en
ai déjà condamné pour la légion et sa
team caisse et the main dans la vie de
ce team en fait en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
médiatisation d'une affaire ou de quoi
que ce soit c'est complètement
inévitable dans le sens où les réseaux
et touba tout tout ce qui est source de
médiatisation en fait c'est vraiment le
centre de la communication
et moi je suis complètement pour parce
que je me dis être seul face à une
affaire donc sans médiatisation est seul
face à une affaire de viol c'est
tellement dur avec tout ce qui à tout ce
qui est administratif et avec la police
avec juste la sphère en général c'est
complètement trop compliqué je pense à
supporter et le fait de la médiatiser ça
permet d'avoir du soutien ça permet
peut-être de servir d'exemple pour
éviter que ça se reproduise
ça permet vraiment d'avoir un soutien
énorme et de tous s'unir
entre une cause excusez moi mais vous
prenez par exemple le cas de deux par
lieu ou en 2019 il ya eu un non lieu
donc la faire elle revient un an après
sur le tapis c'est un tribunal populaire
est en train de parler de gens alors
d'abord on le savait pas qu'il y avait
un non lieu où vous l'avez appris on a
tous eu quasiment appris sur le plateau
qu'est ce qui se passe derrière c'est à
dire que autant gérard depardieu tout le
monde en a un peu peur parce que c'est
un gars solide d'ailleurs vous avez vu
il a balayé en deux minutes
le truc mais vous regardez avec le cas
de richard berry ou le cas de ppda par
rapport au public hier que aujourd'hui
ce sont des gens qui sont coupables
si demain il ya un non-lieu si demain
ils sont blanchis je vous promets que
les gens diront est gelée vécu avec l'
affaire baudis d'un homme qui a été
blanchi c'est ça président du csa qui a
été blanchi qui en est mort c'est l
affaire alègre
il ya des témoins etc troller sur des
plateaux télé qui ont été payés il ya eu
des fausses prostituées qui ont dit
qu'ils avaient vu dominique baudis à
toulouse en des partouzes le mec il en
est mort en huit mois de temps d'un
cancer fulgurant et quand vous parlez
aux gens dans la rue et vous leur
demandez vous leur parlez dominique
baudis
on vous répond il n'y a pas de fumée
sans feu donc à un moment donné il
faudrait juste être un petit peu juste
sur richard berry et on a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois
regardez le cas de richard berry
imaginons que demain on va se mettre des
deux côtés imaginons que richard berry
demain est blanchi c'est aussi une
possibilité il faut pas l'oublier
présomption d'innocence
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que vous
pensez que le mec qui va tourner partout
fait est-ce que vous pensez que l'été
les chaînes de télé vont l'appeler pour
le faire tourner mais bien sûr que non
versant sa carrière a défini elle est
foutue et pépé dass est exactement la
même chose donc arrêter de raconter des
conneries soyez jusqu à ce qu clair non
c'est la même chose pour les victimes
en fait comme il l'a dit cette île la
médiatisation on est dans une ère de
médiatisation ça c'est en fait c'est pas
la faute des victimes ou dépeignant
maintenant je veux dire on n'empêchera
jamais les gens de se faire leur avis
vous avez raison maintenant quand vous
dites tous les gens sont fait leur
opinion richard berry coupable ce n'est
pas vrai il ya énormément de gens qui
soutiennent les mis en cause et les
victimes se font également des
sensations j'aimerais poser la question
gérant
juillet autant d'émotions et de débats
pour défendre les victimes je voudrais
juste donné quelques chiffres
actuellement il ya seulement 10 % des
femmes qui portent plainte pour viol et
sur ces 10 % il y en a 10 % qui vont
aboutir à une condamnation ce qui
rapporte à 1 % le nombre de viols qui
sont condamnés par rapport à ça il ya
moins de 2% de fausses accusations
d'accord il ya une femme sur dix qui est
victime de viol ou de tentative de viol
au cours de sa vie et il ya un une
petite fille sur six garçons mais c'est
un signe les finitions c'est un chiffre
noir c'est un chiffre inconnu je ne sais
pas par quelle méthode vous pouvez
sortir ces stations les amplifier de
l'inad hui à l'insu qui ne sont pas
révélés qui se passe à huit clos ce sont
des chiffres noirs donc ces chiffres moi
je les conseille sur l'âme et la tisza
chalon quand vous dites que la
médiatisation n'est pas le fait des
victimes moi je parle pour le moment des
plaignantes pardonnez-moi mais dans les
affaires dont on parle il y en a une qui
a publié une story sur instagram donc
c'est elle qui médiatise il y en a une
autre qui a écrit un roman c'est elle
l'a encore qui médiatise donc dire c'est
lol jour là mais qu'elle ne se disent
pas victime de la médiatisation
on est tous d'accord qu'on a on sera
ravis ça se passe au niveau de la
justice uniquement actuellement ça ne se
passera pas au niveau de la justice la
justice est totalement défaillante
il n'y a pas de formation aux
psychotropes a oa l'addictologie les
experts fois un nous pollue des
procédures il ne croit pas les enfants
ils rendent des expertises qui sont
emplis de poncifs patriarcaux ça il faut
absolument que ça change ils sont et se
cooptent entre eux il n'y a pas du tout
ce n'est pas cadré
moi je serais ravi que la justice fasse
son travail et qu'on sorte de ce que
vous appelez le tribunal médiatique
idiot mais on est en forme en piano
jouet dire il ya beaucoup de médias qui
sortent les affaires aussi ce sont les
médias parfois qu'ils sortent les
affaires je me demande si c'est leur
rôle de sortir ses affaires quand ya pas
de condamnation est ce que c'est le rôle
du monde du parisien de sortir cdd
affaire banier seront jambes
des gens qui viennent les voir en disant
voilà j'ai été violée il ya des rumeurs
etc et on va pas se mentir il laisse coi
ben on va faire un coup mais est-ce que
c'est leur rôle de sortir j'ai déjà fait
avant qu'ils leur jugement je ne pense
pas qu'il gardait ce qui était rédacteur
en chef du parisien
vous délirez totalement il ya des
journaliers de faits divers dont c'est
le boulot c'est d'aller voir partout les
mains courantes chez les gendarmes les
policiers dans les tribunes auprès des
avocats escales des plaintes c'est quand
il ya des plaintes que les journalistes
sortent à chaque fois vous verrez pas
tarder les plaintes mais arrêtez mais le
boulot des journalistes d'investigation
sortir ça sinon c'est le retour de la
censure mais l'hiver c'est qu'on les
affaires ont été jugées souvent non
jamais il ya une émission de faits
divers
voilà avec un arnaud poivre d'arvor ou
coller mais la pression voilà on est lui
sinon on est lucide et on est coupable
c'est là qu'ils ont que c'est le
contraire vapeur oui ma gueule dit
qu'elle est que les victimes en fait un
signe sur les réseaux sociaux etc
mais elles ont quoi comme autres moyens
pour s'exprimer ces jeunes filles
aujourd'hui le dt temps mana la peau et
un tréteau tribunal esprit va faire
aujourd'hui qu'elles ont la puissance à
côté de ces personnalités dans l'écouté
mais un peu d'argent des familles sont à
l'enjeu y arriverons 1 dans un
commissariat pour déposer la scène
publique
avant j'allais le faire visionner l'oci
non je suis désolé elles n'ont pas
d'autres moyens pers
ah non mais attends désenclaver toi
entendre attendait aujourd'hui vous
rentrez dans un commissariat pour
déposer plainte pour viol je peux vous
dire que vous étiez un blanc
malheureusement la plainte
vous pouvez l'exploit vous pouvez avoir
un avocat à l'aide juridictionnelle sans
conditions de ressources et les délits
sexuels dans la loi aux médisants après
ça c'est la plaignante qui choisit quand
est-ce qu'elle dépose plainte
c'est la porte alors si c'est si facile
pourquoi seulement 10% des femmes
portent plainte pourquoi il ya 80% de
corréler les démons vous aimez ces
chiffres sont comme moi vous voulez vous
connaissez le total de subventions des
femmes qui chantent les schémas date
c'est un chiffre important de la
connaître par définition